[Music]  globalization has made the world  increasingly interconnected and economic  decisions made in one part of the globe  have ripple effects on other parts  measuring economic growth  jobs and environmental effects  based only on national data is not  enough  how can we see the links between jobs  income and trade flows inherent to the  global value chain  in such an interconnected system  well eurostat and the joint research  center of the european commission  have cleverly harmonized and combined  multiple sources  into a new statistical database  creating a new set of integrated global  accounts for economic modeling  called figaro  linking national accounts and data on  business  trade and jobs figaro is now made  available to everyone  a unique tool allowing modelers policy  makers  and other interested parties to analyze  the socio-economic and environmental  effects of globalization  for more information on figaro please go  to the following website  you